selon mathieu bolle-reddat secrétaire
général de la cgt cheminots de
versailles mathieu bonne reda bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en direct sur rt france l'âge
pivot ne figure pas dans le projet de
loi sur les retraites qui sera donc
présenté demain en conseil des ministres
est ce que vous considérez cela comme
une avancée dans vos revendications
alors ce qui est sûr c'est une reculade
du gouvernement donc à mettre à l'actif
de la grève mais évidemment c'est
largement insuffisant je rappelle
d'ailleurs que l'âge pivot concerne le
régime actuel 1 ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'âge des équilibres du régime universel
qui veut être qu'on veut mettre en place
qui fait qu'on devra prendre notre
retraite à taux plein à 60 4 puis 65
puis 67 ans puisque en plus il va se
décaler en fonction des générations
donc en fait c'est l'ensemble du projet
de loi qui est inacceptable et que les
grévistes et les millions de personnes
qui sont dans les rues depuis huit
semaines et encore demain réclame c'est
le retrait voilà c'est le retrait total
que vous demandez pas davantage de
négociations vous aujourd'hui c'est or
le retrait ou rien mais il n'y a aucune
négociation et ça d'ailleurs c'est le
fait du gouvernement puisqu'il ne veut
pas négocier avec les grévistes
puisqu'il dit mon projet c'est ça et
c'est comme ça et pas autrement
j'observe que c'est pas seulement les
grévistes ou la cgt qui réclame le
retrait c'est 61% des français vous
l'avez dit malgré cette grève très dur
on a joué retournement de l'opinion le
pourrissement il ya toujours une immense
majorité des français qui réclament le
retrait donc je pense qu' il serait
temps que le gouvernement arrête
d'essayer violente et ce pays et puis et
puis je retire ce projet rejeté par tout
le monde et demain donc nouvelle
manifestation on le disait ce que vous
attendez à une manifestation massive
après avoir suspendu le mouvement là
dernier bon alors on n'a pas attendu
également en tout cas vous voyez je suis
à mon 50e jour de grève ça s'arrose
et même si les cheminots ou les
traminots adaptent leurs modalités parce
qu'au bout de effectivement 50 jours de
grève c'est juste impossible de
continuer au jour le jour par tranche de
24 heures est bien l'idée de tout le
monde ensemble sur les temps forts
c'est quelque chose de très important
qui va permettre de continuer dans la
durée et je pense que la démonstration
qu'on fait demain avec une remontée des
chiffres de grévistes très importante a
notamment à la ratp mais aussi à la sncf
bien montre que le mouvement s'inscrit
vraiment dans la durée est ce que
justement vous craignez pas
l'exaspération des français par rapport
à ce mouvement qui pourrait durer
justement vous dites dans la durée et
donc avec tout bas ccc métro ces trains
qui ne circulent plus vous ne craignez
pas cette exaspération défaut alors le
retournement de l'opinion nous
l'annoncent depuis dix semaines donc là
je pense qu' il n'arrivera pas faux faut
que tout le monde arrête de se mentir à
soi-même il n'arrivera pas le
retournement de l'opinion
non je pense que l'exaspération qui
expriment les français c'est
l'exaspération vis-à-vis de monsieur
maquereau en fait et son entêtement et
sa violence sa il exprime très bien dans
les sondages que vous avez cité
d'ailleurs alors on observe une
multiplication des opérations coup de
poing comme les coupures d'électricité
sauvage philippe martinez lui soutient
ces méthodes qui sont contestés en
certains grévistes vous est-ce que vous
soutenez ses méthodes
est ce que vous ne craignez pas une
escalade de la violence alors c'est pas
philippe martinez qui soutient ces
méthodes c'est l'ensemble de la cgt qui
soutient ces méthodes donc oui moi bien
sûr à titre personnel je soutiens ces
méthodes
je suis fier aujourd'hui de mes
camarades de la cgt énergie je leur
rends hommage à un hommage appuyé
ils font ce qu'ils ont dit depuis le
début c'est à dire il coupe
symboliquement le courant dans des lieux
de pouvoir et ils remettent et ça on
oublie le signaler l'énergie à des gens
avec qui on l'a coupée notamment il
dormit a démis
de pauvres qui on avait coupé le courant
ils ont remis le courant et où si l'on
passé en heures creuses plus d'un
million de français des clips des
classes populaires
donc c'est très important qu'est ce qui
montre là dedans il montre que le
travail c'est nous en fait un et qu'on
ne va pas imposer au monde du travail
quelque chose et par la grève ou par ce
type d'action il montre qu'il va falloir
compter avec le monde du travail est
encore une classe ouvrière dans ce pays
encore des travailleurs dans ce pays
sauront se faire entendre aujourd'hui on
parlait des négociations tout à l'heure
pour vous c'est fini il n'y en aura plus
il ya plus de dialogue possible sur ce
sujet au genre en fait y'a jamais une
négociation il ya eu un jeu de
négociations entre le gouvernement et
une organisations syndicales non
grévistes que je ne citerai même pas
tellement un an vaut pas la peine
et l'essai n'était mais avec nous avec
les organisations syndicales grévistes
hier aucune négociation la négociation
qui peut les bars est on est on est
vendeur
la négociation s'est je retire ce projet
que rejeté par tout le monde je ouvre
des négociations sur la base de la
défense et du renforcement du régime
existant qui a des problèmes
certainement il ya retrouvons autour
d'une table pour en discuter par alan
cotisation par allons financement
parlant péréquation parlons salaires
parlons retraite parlons prise en compte
des années de chômage et d'études
on est ouvert à la discussion pas de
souci mais là c'est pas une négociation
le gouvernement et fonctionne par oukase
par violence on ne gouverne pas se payer
au coûte
on est en train de montrer aujourd'hui
si rien ne bouge du côté du lieu du
gouvernement à quelle manifestation à
quelles actions pouvons nous nous
attendre dans les prochains jours dans
les prochaines semaines je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce gouvernement il
il déchaîne la violence dans le pays
d'ailleurs il charge les piquets de
grève 1
avec beaucoup de violence avec sa police
il déchaîne la violence dans ce pays
je pense que là il est temps ils
seraient de la responsabilité de
quelqu'un qui se prétend président de la
république en exercice de réconcilier le
pays d'arrêter de le fracturé de reculer
sur ce projet qui divise est justement
de réunir le concert des organisations
syndicales afin de pouvoir ouvrir de
réelles négociations je pense que c'est
sa responsabilité
parce que là ce qu'il est en train de
faire c'est de mettre le pays à feu et à
sang et c'est pas bon bah on le souhaite
pas non plus personne ne le souhaite en
fait
merci beaucoup mathieu bonnard et
d'avoir accepté notre invitation d'eric
sûr être franc je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgt cheminots
de versailles et merci